[Music]
the body becomes its own corset
past present and future exist as a
single force
a swing without gravity soars to a
terrifying height
the outlines of people and things
dissolve countless poets and writers
have tried to put words to the
experience of a panic attack
a sensation so overwhelming many people
mistake it for a heart attack
stroke or other life-threatening crisis
though panic attacks don't cause
long-term physical harm
afterwards the fear of another attack
can limit someone's daily life
and cause more panic attacks studies
suggest
that almost a third of us will
experience at least one panic attack in
our lives
and whether it's your first your
hundredth or you're witnessing someone
else go through one no one wants to
repeat the experience
even learning about them can be
uncomfortable but it's necessary
because the first step to preventing
panic attacks is understanding them
at its core a panic attack is an
overreaction to the body's normal
physiological response to the perception
of danger
this response starts with the amygdala
the brain region involved in processing
fear
when the amygdala perceives danger it
stimulates the sympathetic nervous
system
which triggers the release of adrenaline
adrenaline prompts an increase in the
heart and breathing rate
to get blood and oxygen to the muscles
of the arms and legs
this also sends oxygen to the brain
making it more alert
and responsive during a panic attack
this response is exaggerated well past
what would be useful
in a dangerous situation causing a
racing heart
heavy breathing or hyperventilation the
changes to blood flow cause
lightheadedness and numbness in the
hands and feet
a panic attack usually peaks within 10
minutes
then the prefrontal cortex takes over
from the amygdala
and stimulates the parasympathetic
nervous system
this triggers the release of a hormone
called acetylcholine
that decreases the heart rate and
gradually winds down
the panic attack in a panic attack the
body's perception of danger
is enough to trigger the response we
would have to a real threat
and then some we don't know for sure why
this happens
but sometimes cues in the environment
that remind us of traumatic past
experience
can trigger a panic attack panic attacks
can be part of anxiety disorders
like ptsd social anxiety disorder
ocd and generalized anxiety disorder
recurring panic attacks frequent worry
about new attacks
and behavioral changes to avoid panic
attacks can lead to a diagnosis of a
panic disorder
the two main treatments for panic
disorder are antidepressant medication
and cognitive behavioral therapy or cbt
both have about a 40 response rate
though someone who responds to one may
not respond to the other
however antidepressant medications carry
some side effects
and 50 percent of people relapse when
they stop taking them
cbt meanwhile is more lasting with only
a twenty percent relapse rate
the goal of cbt treatment for panic
disorder is to help people learn
and practice concrete tools to exert
physical
and in turn mental control over the
sensations and thoughts
associated with a panic attack cbt
begins with an explanation of the
physiological causes of a panic attack
followed by breath and muscle exercises
designed to help people
consciously control breathing patterns
next comes cognitive restructuring which
involves identifying and changing the
thoughts that are common during attacks
such as believing you'll stop breathing
have a heart attack or die
and replacing them with more accurate
thoughts
the next stage of treatment is exposure
to the bodily sensations and situations
that typically trigger a panic attack
the goal is to change the belief through
experience
that these sensations and situations are
dangerous
even after cbt taking these steps isn't
easy in the grip of an attack
but with practice these tools can both
prevent and de-escalate attacks
and ultimately reduce the hold of panic
on a person's life
outside formal therapy many panickers
find relief
from the same beliefs cbt aims to
instill
that fear can't hurt you but holding on
to it will escalate panic
even if you've never had a panic attack
understanding them will help you
identify one in yourself or someone else
and recognizing them is the first step
in preventing them
panic attacks can be a common symptom
for those suffering from mental health
disorders
like ptsd and ocd so what causes ptsd
and what does it mean to have ocd
educate yourself
with these videos